I've got a leadership situation I need
help with I was promoted to a troop
commander position over a fellow team
leader who now reports to me
he has many years of experience and a
lot of knowledge he's very he's very
bitter and not getting the promotion at
not getting the promotion and it's
letting me know when I include him in
decision making for the troop or try to
tap into his knowledge and experience he
he shuts down refuses to give input and
says that I should already have the
answer since I'm the troop commander I
know the truth would benefit from his
input and Team Dynamics would be much
improved if it wasn't so negative I've
tried to let him know that I value
I value his experience I feel that his
input would be beneficial and that his
negative attitude and bearing and
bearing are not acceptable it is making
a very ineffective team leader I'm
failing at getting through to him and I
don't want fuck I don't want to fire him
for his position how can I get him to
value his own position in the troop and
become effective again okay I I actually
think you're doing the right thing and
you've opened the door for him so I
think that's a good first initial
approach but obviously doesn't seem to
be working now a couple different
courses of actions you could take one of
the things you could do is actually give
him some higher responsibilities right
even put his team in charge put him in
charge the whole team sometimes maybe he
will step up and start to lead and see
that he's now able to prove that you
have a lot of trust in him and all that
stuff
there's also a chance think about this
there's also a chance that you might be
coming off as condescending to him so
imagine this hey echo I value your
experience oh no all right now you know
the troop would really benefit from your
input it's looks like you're treating
him like it's key he's a kid and he's
getting that those can come off as
condescending so we have to put those a
little bit in check as well and I think
those are a little bit you know you put
to put the person in charge you try that
you've opened up to try and get their
input and get them involved but it's in
might be coming it might be coming
across as condescending even if it's
even if you're doing that even if you're
just saying hey man could really use
your input on this thing it'd be great
you
you're doing it in like a cool way in
your mind you might be hearing oh I
could really use your help a kazoo so
even if you're saying it in a perfect
way it still might be hitting his ears
in a different way so I don't know at
this point I think what I would do is I
would maybe just back off I would just
go forward treating him like one of the
leaders and expect him to perform as you
expect your leaders to perform I think
you've made the effort it didn't really
work and now you have a job to do and
you got to get on with it there's also
you know the world doesn't revolve
around his pouting and his being
negative and and you you can't let that
happen
now on top of that this guy's a powder
and he's a negative guy that's probably
the reason he didn't get selected to be
promoted what we talked about earlier
the boss saw that he saw something along
the way where things didn't go his way
and he and he powered it into his
negative and that's why he didn't get
promoted meanwhile the guy that did get
promoted when things don't go his way
he's like okay cool we'll drive on with
what the new plan is and that's why you
got promoted so I would say move on do
your job
treat him like you would treat one of
your leaders I be very careful that you
don't overcorrect because you hear me
say like okay I'm gonna treat him normal
and now all of a sudden you're treating
him like crap don't do that but treat
him as firmly and as fairly as you would
any one of your subordinate leaders and
we have to see where it goes from there
he may end up just not being able to
deal with this fact I mean there's
there's a reason why some people get
promoted and some people don't and maybe
he's one of these people that can't
humble himself which is one of our
biggest fears in somebody that's trying
to be a leader is that they can't humble
themselves and if that's what's going on
he's gonna have a long hard road and you
know whose fault it's gonna be never his
never gonna be his fault and everyone
else's fault and and that's that'll be
problematic